hello everyone thank you thank you very  much welcome to the Kelly Clarkson show  obviously I'm not Kelly  I love me some Kelly though I wish I was  Kelly Clarkson uh she unfortunately is a  little under the weather and since I'm  around right around the corner I was  happy to step in as today's guest house  so thank you for having me in the show  of course always starts with music and  today is not going to be any different  here is Kelly and her band yaw with post  Malone's better now  [Applause]  [Music]  whoa  do not believe that it would end up  you're not even speaking to my friends  no you know I'm my uncle's in my hands  though  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  don't always say this cause I'm not  around  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  better now you only say that cause I'm  not around  [Music]  yeah it's a jam right there one more  time give it up again for Kelly and her  dance y'all  [Music]  [Applause]  all right  [Applause]  [Music]